something that was funny was when Will  Smith was on the set of Suicide Squad  and he said he first saw the Batmobile  and like freaked out just like lost it  first time you saw the Darth Vader suit  get up on your set for rogue one what  was your reaction how much did you peek  out truthfully well initially I saw the  lovely man he plays him which is to give  a lot away and so we were like having a  child as they how's it going oh it's  great it's great it's great and then as  I was watching as they did one of the  scenes and then suddenly he transforms  and obviously the helmet goes on and  it's it's actually the scariest thing  you've ever seen literally as it gets  loaded onto his shoulders but it was  just magical from start to finish I mean  you just walk onto set and there's like  stormtroopers drinking coffee and  smoking and it's a debate odd sight when  you walk them for wear it's a really  yeah yeah  you